we know there are some things that work
and the first of those that worked is
stemming the flow of firearms used to
commit violent crimes
we responded immediately when we saw
those shooters with assault rifles that
hit
our college campuses in suburban
counties and it was the right thing to
do
but the problem in america is the
handgun
yet the demographics of the victims are
black brown and poor
we have ignored it for far too long
let's talk about all of this bringing
our panel early trey gowdy former
congressman from south carolina
harold ford jr former tennessee
congressman ceo of empowerment
and inclusion capital and as mentioned
before a special panelist tonight
jesse waters co-host of the five author
of the new book
how i saved the world this is a rare
event jesse
it is i'm feeling very special and i
will try not to ruin your show
thank you trey let's start with you all
this talk about guns and gun reform
at the white house your thoughts about
how the white house is handling this how
president biden
is talking about this violence across
the country
well you know brett gun prosecutions
went down under president obama with
vice president biden
right there beside him i i mean i i want
your viewers
to focus on the group that constantly
calls for more gun laws
gun prosecutions went down when they
were in office so what we know is
defunding the police doesn't work
this bond reform doesn't work these
so-called progressive prosecutors don't
don't work i got a really crazy novel
idea
how about actually enforce you'd be
shocked brett at the
gun laws we currently have but they
don't do any good
if the federal prosecutors aren't
actually enforcing them so how about we
start there
harold there does seem to be a split
between some democrats and how they talk
about this and what the white house is
kind of messaging on this
well first off congrats to jesse on the
book and thanks for having me on
i don't think that there's as much of a
gap as we think the leader of the
democratic party has never been for
defending the police
he convened a group of law enforcement
officials to talk candidly
to talk seriously and broadly about how
to address this issue the democratic
nominee in the largest city in the
country that has witnessed and
experienced some of the great crime
reductions over the many years and i
might add
i would agree with trey gun prosecution
should go back up but during it
by an administration excuse me the obama
administration crime and violent crime
rates were down in a lot of cities but
they're going up now and it causes
it calls for a different set of
reactions so i was encouraged by this
meeting i'm encouraged by
even the willingness to listen to some
of the bell reform changes that must
happen
i think there were some who were
well-intentioned that wanted bail reform
but it's not working
it's putting criminals and putting
violent people back out on the street
there has to be a better way to achieve
what some of those who wanted bail
reform to achieve without endangering
our communities as we as we certainly
have
and finally we should go after ghost
guns they're right about that and i hope
they continue
continue that pursuit you know we just
saw the report from matt fenn
the chicago police superintendent
talking about
the disregard for police on the streets
take a listen
there's no regard for law enforcement's
presence
at these scenes to bring them to justice
they will
fire weapon at law enforcement
or at others for what what appears to be
uh no apparent reason jesse your
thoughts
well the country's been too permissive
when it comes to all of these
precincts in liberal america the gun
issue is a dodge
we have the strictest gun laws in these
cities
so it's really just about enforcement if
you're a gang banger brett
and you get popped for illegal
possession of a firearm
you could be booked out same day back on
the street
and when it is time for sentencing if a
liberal d.a only recommends one year
instead of the three to seven and the
public defender
says okay let's just go 10 days liberal
judge is just going to slice it in half
and give him six months
so he's paroled in six months back out
squeezing the trigger
and comes into contact with the law
enforcement that's under siege
by liberal activists so unless we're not
talking about incarceration and
prosecution
i don't believe this is a serious issue
with the democrats joe biden's doing
great on kovid
big numbers in terms of approval but
with crime
and the border he's in his 30s and you
add
critical race theory to that you add gas
prices to that
eventually the covet thing is going to
become not an issue anymore
and he's got some stuff that's just
really just
right there at the edge waiting to take
him down so he needs to fix this
quickly but i don't see it happening you
know trey some media organizations at
the beginning of
as we were covering it here on fox said
you know we were blowing it up
out of proportion that this really
wasn't crime wasn't an issue across the
country
and now there's this meeting at the
white house obviously it's risen to the
level politically
how does that fall you know as we get
closer and closer to 2022
well look i mean there are lots of folks
on the democrat side harold ford
included that are really smart when it
comes to politics i mean you look at jim
clyburn and others they want to hold on
to the house and they know
that if the economy is okay and kova's
okay
public safety is the number one function
of government so if you can't do that
and look let's be fair most of this
crime is state and local
but when you have democrat members of
congress talking about the police the
way
rashida talib and and omar and aoc talk
about the cops
then it's going to trickle into the
federal system he gets to pick u.s
attorneys let's pick some that actually
believe in putting
people violent offenders in prison
that'd be a great place to start
quit with the progressive prosecutors
pick u.s attorneys that actually believe
in enforcing gun laws
all right panel we'll see you at the
bottom of the show and
you know we'll do another book tease
down there too jesse okay all right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else